[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
for that fight about the clock is really
what's the matter Chum didn't you like
it
that's so funny little slap-happy guys
sleep like a baby
sure okay so you're like look you so
what so you're lucky that's all
[Music]
maybe you should take a warm shower
before you hit the sack but maybe you
don't eat right could be the details
runs too tough you know what you need is
[Music]
give us hair that boy
so why don't you try it now buds forget
it well you know I've been wondering
what's come over you so since you don't
get an easier to live with
oh so you don't have to be so touchy
come on
thanks be yourself all right so she
hasn't written for a couple of weeks
three weeks does that mean anything
don't worry so much I'd be a worrywart
look at me I never worry what does it
get you worrying all the time
why why how am I gonna get those lead
papers signed by Saturday night I could
worry about that do kinda but not enough
to stew all night
come on that time we're moving in on
Saipan didn't sleep a wink
boo dick
wasn't anything I could do about it
sure urban times I couldn't sleep school
night before exam first time ever went
to the dentist why this please is the
rich a little nut things like that I'll
keep you awake maybe but Q you stay
awake night after night don't seem to
have anything on your mind you do you
don't tell a guy about it
[Applause]
you know right
I don't get it well maybe you'll really
get some shut-eye tonight huh
place a
[Music]
[Music]
go to sleep
go to sleep
why can't I get some sleep
night after night
they can't take it
rather be dead probably will die nobody
nobody can last above sleep
night after night
night after night after night oh no
you're not gonna die we know how you
feel but in all medical history nobody's
ever died from lack of sleep
before that can happen nature will take
over and give you the rest and sleep
that you need whether you realize it or
not but you're worried you've got
something on your mind that's what keeps
you lying there staring at the ceiling
everybody does that once in a while look
at lucky right now
he's still awake insomnia well that's
only a vague medical term let's see
what's going on in his mind each man's
problem is more or less different but
here is one time listen damn it the hell
what's the matter with me I gotta get
some sleep
goes on I'm gonna wound up like a top
talking to that guy fine now I can't
sleep wound up like a top yes that's a
good way to put it and getting round up
excitement anticipation minor in
decisions confusion anything like that
is a sure way to postpone sleep you have
to unwind before you can rest listen to
it come on I get those papers put true
why did I have to get myself in the
doghouse with a chief
I'm gonna go see the bunch hello I can't
help him
it's a Doc's job sure see the doc it
goes on and on and the mall wound up he
gets the worst it is that's just tension
he doesn't have to do this
tension that's all but he won't get any
real rest when he's all wound up like
that let's see what he does about all
right they can't sleep so why can't you
sleep eat too much too much coffee to
learn me not fair yeah
that's okay
I have a clean shirt
I see the doc maybe I can
I gonna sleep don't get it
forget the papers forget buns
right
[Music]
should I
[Applause]
get the idea here's the whole business
in a nutshell at first his thoughts had
him on a merry-go-round
then he took control and pinned down the
cause he was doing around about you and
about his lead but once he decided what
his troubles were her and decided he
couldn't do anything about them tonight
that was that he began to relax and look
at him now
Lucky's method won't work for you will
it
your problem isn't quite that easy if it
were as simple as one two three you
wouldn't be lying awake night after
night maybe you know what's bothering
you and maybe you don't exactly that
happens to lots of people sometimes they
can't put the finger right on the cause
and sometimes they can but refuse to
admit it even to themselves you know
we're all a little different it's
interesting to look around just one word
and see just how different we are
the kind of person we were to start with
and how we've been brought up they make
a difference in the way we react to our
problems maybe it's a question of
marriage
money jar
maybe it's a question of getting along
with others but again sometimes it's a
question of getting along with ourselves
or just plain lack of purpose maybe it's
a combination
it may be purely physical like a tooth
day for a recent operation but whatever
it is there's no cure every guys worry
is a personal problem if each one of
these men had a stomachache would you
give him the same dose of medicine no of
course not
they're all different you'd tell him to
see the doctor and get individual
attention
that's what you ought to do tomorrow
tell the doc what's on your mind
but we can give you some help right now
what detail you on bunts blatant squirt
Browns cars machines Oh responsible work
now think back over the jobs you did
today
I spent most of the day on my back under
a truck feeling something like a spring
that's wound up too tight well yeah kind
of tied up in knots the back of the neck
the back of the neck elbows chest yeah
it's funny I like to fiddle with that
screwdriver and the first thing I know
I'm trying to figure things out I get to
talking away not loud you understand my
jaws are working and here in the ward
you go on doing the same thing trying to
work things out in your head about the
way lucky was doing a few minutes ago
yeah did you ever wind the watch too
tightly you have to wind it but if he
wind it too tight the spring freezes
tight and the watch stops the right
amount of tension keeps the watch for
you
ticking along in good shape you're two
tents all day long a child or just
walking from one building to another
you're wound up tight all the time day
and night you don't think about it
during the day because something's
always going on but at night you keep
right on generating energy with no good
way to get rid of it result
you not only lie awake but you worry
about being away
now see if we can't channel that energy
so even if you are awake you get some
rest let's start with your head and
relax gradually all the way down well
that's easy to say but how do you do it
well get this first relaxing the skill
like hitting a target it takes practice
concentration and Mura practice go ahead
start getting comfortable right now
eventually relaxing becomes automatic
and you can do it without thinking I
hope you're right
to begin with spit out flat on the bed
get in a position that suits you best
that's better
straighten out okay
right quietly but don't force yourself
the whole still if you are at the
control panel imagine you're going to
switch off the current to the tight
places one knob at a time slow and easy
start by turning off that worried look
he's into a smile not a smirk loosen the
pearls on your Florida
now around your nose between your eyes
your mouth is relaxed
and already there's less tension in your
shoulders less tension in your arm your
fists loosen them up one at a time take
a good breath now yawn you don't feel
like you're a fake one again
next relieve that pressure from your
neck think of it as pulling out a row of
stitches unraveling them one at a time
then your back muscle relax them to let
the pressure off the thigh muscles
take them nuts out of the cat muscles
relax the right leg
left leg firmly ankle one at a time your
feet your toes
remember that sock in the Donald Duck
picture imagine it dropped just plop
that's how you should lie there plop
down limp and now will you sleep well if
you can't the doctor will help you but
at least you'll be in condition to pass
the night rest fully and comfortably
[Music]